[Music]
we did get to do a fun movie together
back in the day we got to do a scene for
this movie going the distance
the first movie i was ever really in
really going the distances with you and
justin long and i remember it because
what do you remember about it i'll tell
you what i remember about it um
while i was dating him at the time you
were dating him and then what what
happens when that
happens mean that's that's not a great
question
what happens with that
well we're not the first people to meet
on the set and have a romance well okay
so so what i remember about it we were
shooting through the night in the middle
in the middle of the night at this
restaurant in the west side and um
every time we'd finish a scene we'd walk
out
and
paparazzi would just be photographing
you and him and i was just oh
wow that's a really weird life existence
it is it is like because that's like
your belief
it's weird i didn't get why we were ever
an interesting couple like that didn't
make any sense to me yeah like why who
cares
we're not exciting
i think you were excited i don't see it
that way
and no offense to justin yeah i just was
like this is not that this is not you
know
that kind this is not working
i mean this wasn't coined at the time
but you were very long
just a long very moment
that's not bad i was very much in love
with justin i you know why
because he's funny very funny guy the
sharpest wit you want to know why he
gets all the ladies
well there's a few reasons
definitely uh
like he he is one of the sharpest
wittiest
uh he's brilliant and he just he'll just
knock your socks off with laughter i
never told you this story when i first
moved to new york i was walking through
central park there's like this sort of
maze of gardens like a conservatory area
i was walking through and i was like oh
there's hugh grant and then i walked a
little longer like there's drew
barrymore and no one's around we were
filming music i didn't realize it was
music and lyrics until the movie came
out now hugh and i did not date
yes i was so upset because when i met
him it turns out he's a totally grumpy
old man
and you're like wait no you're hugh
grant you're supposed to be like the
dashing rom-com guy what is going on and
then you fall in love with him for the
real hue and he's the greatest guy ever
and i love him so much
he's so wonderful and he is so
funny
he he comes on the show and we give our
editors a nightmare because he's he's
he's
a reverend
and we go to some funny weird
places that would not be appropriate
it makes sense that you're friends
though because
that movie is great really
it's great are you kidding me i never
get to watch it because it's like i'm in
it i'm watching my movie tonight that
would be so awful but i i love that
movie and i wish i could revisit it
should watch it again oh maybe i'll show
it to my daughters it's so good it's got
great songs in it
i'm glad you like it
you